allez les grands temps d'accueillir un
artiste hors norme hors pair chez
monsieur arthur manquer dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis fan de c'est quoi la mode et art
en tant qu'arrière sepa décontracté
franchement excusez moi je réponds moi
qui ai déjà 40 ans de carrière
oui j'ai déjà 61 ans si tu peux
comprendre de tous contre les chercheurs
ces 61 oui je vais créer mon livre le
secret de la jeunesse fait faire un peu
de fric et de michel drucker de la magie
celui-ci met dans le frigo la nuit mal
bien alors jusqu'au 3 février
il est au théâtre faut les voir moi je
disais je vous ai vu il ya quelques
années oui c'était absolument pas le
même mais dallas le même pas une ride
rien incroyable j'ai fait nouveau
spectacle s'appelle solo solo sur l'opa
seul avec son lot d'artistes le solo du
maître de la métamorphose
vous avez changé comme un personnel vous
avez en tout les différents personnages
raison soit 100 rivière-saint-louis 60
voix ah oui 16 personnes en tournée pour
bébé les coulisses oui mais je fais pas
seulement changements de costumes il y
aussi des hommes chinoise la peinture
sur sable de la lutte laser et vous êtes
avec magiciens
oui comme comme lui les magiciens les
magiciens après ce que je mets en avant
plutôt les artistes dans le cadre de
spectacles de magie mais en tout cas
vous vous êtes sûrement vers l'avant